[Musique]
je suis effeuilleuses burlesques donc
aussi bien performeur c'est à dire que
je me produis sur scène mais je suis
aussi professeur je donne des cours
d'effeuillage à des femmes à des hommes
de tout âge de tout corporalité de toute
histoire de vie
on a une partie théorique en fait avant
la partie pratique la partie théorique
se compose de 45 minutes autour de
différents thèmes l'estiment de soi la
confiance le lâcher prise le lien avec
le corps la gestion des émotions et donc
fatalement elles sont amenées à se
livrer pendant les cours sur leur vie et
ensuite on a 45 minutes de pratique donc
une chorégraphie avec de l'effeuillage
[Musique]
c'est important pour moi d'avoir une
histoire de vie derrière la personne qui
arrive parce qu'elle va être bien
travaillé avec aussi bien ses échecs que
ces réussites son expérience de vie d'un
point de vue global va lui servir dans
les feuillages parce que moi j'aime bien
que les tableaux voilà permettent au
public de transposer un petit peu et y
reconnaître
[Musique]
fatalement ça me nourrit en même temps
faut pas trop que je m'en nourris ce non
plus parce que il faut que je sois là en
toute neutralité pour les orienter au
mieux sur ce qu'elles sont en train de
me dire ce qu'elles sont en train de
traverser sur les solutions par exemple
quel m'expose et oui effectivement on
est sur des expériences de vie entre
rires et larmes comme n'importe quel
être humain on a des moments difficiles
on a des moments plus facile l'idée
c'est de réussir à tous les accepter et
et à travailler avec tous ces moments
est bon là c'est pas forcément très
qu'ovide ce que je vais dire mais il fut
un temps où on avait quand même beaucoup
de dents dans l'asthme ans après a
pressé ses larmes et puis au niveau du
groupe les élèves me dit souvent que
well et les cours en présentiel les
manques que le fait de pouvoir se
touchent et de pouvoir rigoler ensemble
de de pouvoir se regarder dans les yeux
vraiment sans être on va dire bloqué par
un écran voilà un fatalement ça change
tout ce côté qui manque le plus là dans
mon activité c'est le côté humain c'est
le côté où tout le monde arrive et c'est
un peu comme la bande de potes qui se
retrouvent une fois par semaine et et
avec qui on si on va passer un bon
moment
moi je croyais jamais été coincé
j'ai jamais non jamais de trop de souci
d'aider steam ou de confiance j'ai la
chance d'avoir des parents qui pour le
coup est un cercle familial qui accepte
et relativement bien le style dans
lequel j'étais le fait que j'étais
maquiller les talons ça les a pas plus
choqué de ça quand je leur ai dit bah
voila j'ai monté ma boîte je suis fait
ça a été un bon c'est bien
[Musique]
dita crazy